you guys know that this diet definitely
has some problems but we're gonna make
it better hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen literally
today
[Music]
we are going to be going where no other
dietitian has gone before I'm gonna be
attempting Kelly Ripa's diet as
chronicled in her harp as bizarre
interview but of course your girl's
gotta make some modifications okay so a
lot of you may remember my review of
Kelly Ripa's Harper's Bazar what Aina
day it was in short problematic so much
so that the original copy on Harper's
Bazaar got taken down and then Kelly's
team reached out to us to ask us to take
our copy down so her team explained it
to me like Kelly was on some kind of
cleanse during the interview but she
actually described it as how she eats
for 365 days a year every day I mean no
judgment for me either way but it does
seem like a kind of poor defense anyway
in my original video I gave some
suggestions on how I would potentially
improve some of Kelly's meals but today
I thought we would take it one step
further and actually show you yup I'm
gonna be eating like Kelly Ripa Circa
2020 and folks you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my general disclaimer the original diet
recall is very restrictive and may be
triggering to some folks so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also please
do not use this as a recommendation of
what or how you should eat this is
simply what I ate on a specific day to
meet my own needs it is meant only for
inspiration not comparison finally guys
if you are not already subscribed please
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to follow me over on Tick Tock
and Instagram at Abby's kitchen before
we get into the video we're gonna build
a hunger crushing combo tool kit
okay so today I'm feeling like some
healthy fats and pistachios fiber and a
beautiful pear and protein in one of my
favorite build bars the peanut butter
brownie you guys know I love these build
bars because they come in so many
different fun flavors like peanut butter
brownie what's not to love and they
taste like real chocolate because they
are made with chocolate but they are
packed with quality protein this bad boy
right here has 19 grams and it tastes
amazing I don't know anything about real
power tools but this is a snack toolbox
that I can get behind so if you guys
want to try build bars for yourself you
can check out my link in the description
and use my promo code abbysharp15 to get
15 off of your order all right back to
the kitchen okay so according to Kelly
she always starts her day with this get
off your acid greens powder which
according to her is for alkalinizing the
digestive system I take a glass of water
and I have something called get off your
acid Daily Greens which is spirulina
spinach kale all ground to a powder that
you mix into water and it is for
alkalining your digestive system okay
Kelly I'm just gonna
right there to ask why would anyone
actually want to alkalinize their
digestive system like there's a reason
why our stomach pH comfortably stays
between one and two because without
adequate hydrochloric acid in the gut to
help to digest food we would have
serious digestive distress hair loss
bloating vomiting you name it so I can
assure you that no greens powder will
effectively change the pH of your gut it
also will not change your blood pH
because if it did Kelly and basically
every other Wellness influencer on Tick
Tock would die if you want to learn more
about greens powders and some major red
flags you can watch out for you can
check out my full video right here so
yeah I'm just gonna have regular old
water
with my vitamins because that's
basically what I think Green's powder
really is like a powdered multivitamin
with maybe a little bit of flavor there
is little to no fiber in those
supplements so ultimately it's never
going to replace real whole veg
okay so next Kelly apparently has a
large coffee blended with ghee and you
know what I say about that guys your
coffee order is sacred I don't touch
that
you drink how you like it but if I'm
honest for myself
ghee coffee not my style Abby any
thoughts actually yes butter coffee
gained popularity thanks to an interest
in interim fasting keto and Whole30 and
ghee essentially takes it one step
further by removing any of the milk
solids which means fewer carbohydrates
and lactose and while our dietary
guidelines still do tend to demonize
better and other saturated fats recent
evidence has found it to have a pretty
small or even neutral association with
mortality cardiovascular disease and
diabetes he is also thought to be
healthier than butter because it's a
greater source of butyric acid which has
some gut health benefits and conjugated
linoleic acid which very early research
has shown some small benefits for weight
loss having said that I would never
suggest adding more like pure fat to the
diet to help support weight loss I mean
any small benefits from the fatty acids
are definitely going to be refuted by
the fact that you're adding in calories
and extra fat but if you like the flavor
in your coffee I think it's great option
so yeah I'm just going to drink my
normal latte how I like it and I also
kind of feel like I've had enough fluids
for the day and I'm needing to eat
something so let's talk about the food
um I could probably just tell you what
Kelly Ripa eats in a day but I also just
feel like she says it best so let's take
a look a green apple
cut out and then I take two tablespoons
of almond butter and a teaspoon of
cinnamon I blend it all together and I
put the apples in there and I eat that
like a porridge if you will and that is
my first chewable food of the day yeah
we won't be doing that okay I love that
we have some Fiber in the apples and
some healthy fats in the almond butter
but there's just not enough protein or
carbs or calories to satisfy my big girl
appetite so yeah we're gonna have to
bulk this up so yeah I'm feeling like
we're gonna do real porridge like actual
oatmeal
um rather than like almond butter Apple
paste but we're gonna flavor it up Kelly
style let's do it oh
Anthony does this all right let's make
some protein oatmeal
all right
a couple scoopies
one more
I like to do a mix of water
and some kind of milk we're going with
this protein milk
probably good always a generous pinch of
salt you cannot cook oatmeal without it
in my opinion and I'd rather it be too
thick and then add more than a vice
versa because then it gets impossible to
revive you guys know we love me some
hemp hearts
that's going in
loads of healthy fats and my kids will
be upset to know that I'm using their
snack packs for
my breakfast
I want a snack
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time do we want our apples crunchy soft
crunchy soft I'm gonna do half and half
because I can't decide should we get
some of it like cooked down nicely
and then some on top for crunch
I'm not satisfied with that portion
I'm gonna add some almond butter in
honor of Kelly
I know she's into that
um
all right this is looking good to me
this is how all women make oatmeal in
the morning
just to get in those slo-mo hero shots
um
all right anyways I need to add some
extra protein I've got some vanilla
protein powder you can use whatever you
like I'm gonna stir that in and
typically this thickens it up even more
so I'll just add a little bit more
milk
there we go
it's my style that's the texture
your girl likes all right let's plate
her up
all right a little bit on top
Kelly look at this Hilly's a queen don't
get me wrong and I feel like she rocks
her show every single day but if it were
me having to do live television early in
the morning I would need something like
this on board
so good all right let's see what we're
doing next after I wrap for the day I
work out seven days a week I don't work
out seven days a week because I believe
as the research suggests that our bodies
need rest and you know what I think my
body needs rest today so I do try to
move my body gently every days and I
still have to take poppy for a walk but
you know muscles cannot grow and recover
if we are training them extensively
every day but you smell Poppy
you know as I'm walking here I'm just
thinking how insane it would be for me
personally to have to like get up early
go on live television be on my a game do
a whole full workout on just like an
apple with some almond butter like I'm
not surprised that video got taken down
all right pops
all right finally it's time for lunch
and apparently Kelly's go-to is a big
salad with micro greens avocado and lots
of nuts plus a daily avocado toast which
she says kick of 2015 to 2017. it was
two years where avocado toast was pretty
much the foundation of my diet listen I
love avocado toast but could I see
myself eating it every single day maybe
multiple times a day for like two years
absolutely not even if I want to opening
up a perfect ripe avocado every single
day seems like a miracle same with the
nuts really like we had a lot of nut
butter at breakfast and we're having
more nuts here at lunch
and nuts are super nutritious but if
we're relying on nuts and avocado to
basically make up the bulk of our meals
we're displacing other important
nutrients in our day most notably
protein between those two first meals of
the day they're just as not enough
protein to support muscle protein
synthesis post-workout protein is key
for post-workout muscle protein
synthesis and while we don't necessarily
need to be eating immediately after a
workout as we used to think we do want
to make sure that we're getting a full
dose of protein about 0.3 to 0.4 grams
per kilogram of body weight per meal
within four hours or so of our training
so for most folks that is somewhere
around the 20 to 30 gram per meal Mark
and even if we were to add an egg to the
avocado toast as Kelly says that she
sometimes does I would say that we are
still falling short of our recovery
needs so yeah I didn't even do a heavy
workout today and I know I need more
protein to feel satisfied so let let's
turn this into a hunger crushing combo
all right so we've got some greens as
our base these actually came from my
hubby's vertical farm so they are Super
Fresh and delicious so we're gonna add
those down
um what's next we need some avocado here
which clearly she loves her avocado so
let's
add some avocado on top that's some
healthy fats we've got some of the nuts
which she loves I'm adding some
Cranberries for some kind of extra
carbohydrates and sweetness oh we
definitely need some protein in here
magic of Television look at that all
right so yeah throw some chicken breasts
on top whatever you know whatever you
got on hand that's looking good
yum and what else
maybe some little basil leaves let's see
and this is a dressing that I made it's
like a tahini
tahini based um Green Goddess dressing
so we'll just do a little drizzle
drizzle
if the drizzle cooperates
wow also so good though all right that's
this drizzly as she's gonna come uh
Saladin we need some avocado toast so
this is my strange favorite way to make
avocado toast you can just smash an
avocado right onto your sourdough toast
or whatever toast you like but this is
really how I like it just for some extra
flavor and some extra protein so grab a
handful of white beans whoop lost one
throw in your avocado
I like a little cream cheese you can
also like spread it first but you can
also just mix it right in because I like
the flavor and the tang and the
cheesiness obviously you can omit if you
are keeping a vegan we've got some fresh
basil and some chives some lemon juice
it's going to keep everything nice and
green get in there with some salt
some Peppy
good
just to get the party started oh
it's such a mess for just lunch
let's blend all right so I got my
favorite sourdough
so so good just toasted that lightly
I'm gonna smear on
this avocado mixture
so we bumped up the protein here we
bumped up the fiber we've got our
healthy fats obviously in our avocado
and our nuts lots of avocado really so
yummy
uh I'm gonna do some tomatoes because
why not get a little extra Sweetness in
there beaut and I'm obsessed with
balsamic drizzle so that's usually how I
like to top it
a little hemp heart action
for some Crunch and healthy fats and all
the good stuff and you guys know I'm
obsessed I might just throw on some
extra herbs since we're getting fancy I
mean only the best for the queen of
daytime television Beauty oh actually
oh no
salt fail but we don't waste
nice
done let's get in okay this is a serious
upgrade if I may say so myself we have
protein
amazing in the chicken and a little bit
in the white beans that I period into
the avocado toast we have tons of
healthy fats clearly that's kind of
Kelly's Jam avocado avocado nuts and a
dressing that's tahini based which is
also super delish we've got some carbs
here with our sourdough plus I added
more with the cranberries and lots of
beautiful micronutrients and greens this
looks delicious I don't even know where
to start but let's get a piece of
chicken in here because I feel like I
need some more protein
my husband would hate me for putting all
of this in my mouth but you know what
we're going for it
that dressing slaps let's talk about
snacks handfuls of nuts lots of raw
cashews lots of raw almonds lots of raw
pistachios I never eat more than a
handful but I have several handfuls a
day yeah I thought we went over this but
it's becoming kind of apparent that
there are really only a handful of safe
foods literally in Kelly's diet and the
fact that she has kind of like a rule
around serving size is even more
concerning just a quick note that rules
like sticking to no more than a handful
of nuts per day are classic 1990s diet
culture this is one of those
oversimplified nutrition suggestions to
help people estimate a serving size of
nuts when we actually know that a
serving size is not a recommendation of
how much you should eat but rather how
much most people usually eat so if
you're needing to have a handful of nuts
multiple times a day to feel satisfied
you probably just need to eat more
calories and ideally more protein at
your actual meals and this is something
that I'm fairly confident about in the
context of this particular day I've
personally found that my digestion is a
lot better when I have bigger meals and
snacks as opposed to grazing throughout
the day so I'm going to bulk up Kelly's
snack to make it more satiating and more
satisfying and turn it into a hunger
crushing combo let's do it so I know
that Kelly loves cashews I also love
cashews
but if I just have like a handful of
nuts I'm just not gonna feel satisfied
so I'm gonna add some nuts we've got
mango which I feel like goes so nicely
with cashews
for a little carb action and then I've
just cooked some frozen edamame
also super yum great source of protein
very hot but
delish
Hmm this is basically a locally made
tahin seasoning it's like spicy limey
kind of sweet it's delicious and it goes
on all these things so
tell me that does not look delicious
mango tahini oh come on bud
so delicious really takes it to the next
level all right let's talk dinner which
I'm already not super jazzed about
because it's a lot of the same same so
apparently Kelly has the same salad that
she had for lunch for dinner plus more
grilled greens or some other kind of veg
and some kind of like tofu or tahini for
plant-based protein can we all now agree
that folks who most often take these
greens powder supplements are the people
who really don't need them I mean it's
always ironic to me when people load up
on these greens powders which claim to
help to reduce bloating but then like
overload their meals in their plates
with all these high FODMAP raw veg we
have to remember that varieties of spice
of life and while green veg are of
course super nutritious they may be
missing key antioxidants that other
colorful vegetables Supply things like
lycopene and tomatoes anthocyanins in
cabbage and indoors in cauliflower some
of which are actually enhanced when you
cook them and others are best when
they're raw so enjoying a wide range of
produce some raw and some cooked will
help you meet your nutrient needs with
the lowest risk of digestive distress
honestly I just can't do any more greens
like I feel like my FODMAP bucket has
been filled to the brim and I'm likely
going to be up all night farting I also
don't understand why there's no carbs in
this meal honestly this day of eating
has been so impossibly low in calories
and high in volume but it honestly feels
like a bit of a chore just to think
about eating this dinner we can amp this
up all right so I have pressed and
marinated a little bit of tofu in olive
oil lemon zest salt and pepper and zatar
popping it into my Air fryer here
poop how do we do this let's make some
carbs okay so last minute I just
parboiled some new potatoes baby
potatoes and I'm gonna pan fry them
because this is my kids favorite way to
eat potatoes need a little olive oil a
lot
well I'm Crispy
leave them alone
lots of salt
foreign
all right we got some crispy potatoes
for our carbs I'll save some for my kids
we've got some colorful veggies
and
so good
crispy crispy all right this is like a
tahini Maple dressing that I made it's
actually going to do wonders on this as
well
and
poppy she's like you've been cooking all
day long give me something to eat
anyways little zatar
uh I feel like this is
a solid meal
way better than just more salad and
vegetables all right let's recap here
folks okay we got protein in the tofu
because I know that's Kelly's fave plus
I added the tahini which I know she also
loves I'm counting that more as like a
fat that has a little bit of protein
even though I know that Kelly said that
it's kind of her go-to protein anyways
it's all in the mix also add some
potatoes for cars because let's be real
you're a girl needed that and instead of
the same same salad and the kind of
braised or grilled greens which let's be
real we've done to death I went for some
nice colorful bell peppers protein fats
fiber looks great
oh my gosh that's good
all right let's talk about dessert and
Trigger warning folks because this is
where it gets bad in general in general
terms I try not to cheat too much what I
will indulge in is like a delicious
chocolate covered almond or chocolate
covered cashew some sort of like so I
still feel like there's something
healthy in there I think we can all
agree that Harper's Bazaar did the right
thing in taking this video down a single
chocolate almond is not dessert and only
allowing yourself something sweet
because it has something healthy in it
is a huge red flag to me so in the name
of challenging some of these problematic
diet rituals I'm not going to have
anything healthy at all I'm gonna have a
bowl of ice cream no protein no healthy
fats no fiber just delicious ice cream
and I'm not even gonna make it into a
hunger crushing combo because sometimes
it's totally okay if your meals are not
balanced honestly we had lots of veggies
today plus lots of protein and healthy
fats it's okay to have dessert just the
way you like it because my health
depends on having a balanced
relationship with food and cookies and
cream
she just hits different
so what can we say about Kelly's day of
eating well it was rough considering I
had to change basically like everything
in the diet recall I would say it left a
lot to be desired it was low in calories
low in carbs low in protein and most
importantly a very low in pleasure Even
If This Were to be some kind of detox
cleanse short term as Kelly's team
claimed it would likely do nothing more
than trigger some kind of rebound binge
when you finally let yourself eat
something other than avocados and nuts
I'm sorry Kelly I love you I love you I
think you are beautiful you're
intelligent you're hilarious
but this diet is not it well guys that
is all that I have for you guys today if
you like this type of video please give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on Whose diet you'd like to see me
try and build on subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]